the reality is that Cleopatra she was
the last member of this dynasty the
ptolemaic Dynasty in Egypt which went
all the way back to the death of
Alexander the Great and the division of
Alexander's Empire among his Macedonian
generals so the result of that was a
Greek dynasty was established based in
Alexandria and are they by and large I
mean there's very little evidence that
they ever married anybody who wasn't
also Greek indeed sometimes brothers and
sisters married which was an Egyptian
practice one that the Greeks actually
detested
so really you know all the evidence we
have including also the Visual Evidence
because there are quite a lot of
portraits which are thought to be of
Cleopatra you can't always be sure show
her looking very very Greek
and then all her predecessors apart from
herself none of them even spoke the
Egyptian language